spider-man is back after the tragic
ending of infinity war a lot of us were
worried about the future of our favorite
web slinger but Tom Holland returns in
this fresh trailer for spider-man far
from home although it may leave you with
more questions than answers what just
happened
does far from home take place before or
after Avengers endgame who are the
villains in this movie and who's Jake
Gyllenhaal is supposed to be playing to
start spider-man
far from home appears to take place
after the events of Avengers and game
Sony producer Amy Pascal revealed that
spider-man far from home takes place
just a few minutes after the end of
endgame that makes this trailer
extra-special being the only way to get
a peek at the world after endgame
premieres this April and let's be honest
we're all curious who's gonna survive
the Mad Titans invasion so let's take a
closer look a lot of familiar faces make
a return in this trailer Marisa Tomei
returns as Aunt May who discovered Peter
Parker's secret at the end of homecoming
that may seem to have adjusted to Peters
alter-ego as the to play a part in
running a homeless shelter a storyline
from both the comics and the ps4
videogame Jon Favreau is back as happy
Hogan who was a big part in the first
film he shows up with a check from
synchrony Bank a little nod to the
actual bank that issues Marvel credit
cards they seems that Aunt May and happy
Hogan might just be more than friends
new dress what just happened the trailer
also nods to a character we're all
familiar with but have never seen in the
MCU Uncle Ben hinted at by the initials
on the suitcase that Peter brings to
Europe Peter is not alone on his trip to
Europe zendaya returns as Michelle MJ
Jones the movies version of Mary Jane
Watson
it appears that MJ will be Peters love
interest as their romance is heavily
foreshadowed throughout the trailer I
spent some time with MJ
watch YouTube and Flash Thompson who
just like in the comics bullies Peter
Parker but ironically admire spider-man
as a hero what he looks out for the
neighborhood has a dope suit in my
really respective sup dickwad and of
course how can we forget Peters best
friend Ned awesome which leads our first
surprising reveal the return of Nick
Fury considering Fury died after the
events of infinity war it seems like the
character will be brought back to life
and judging by his first words so nice
to finally meet you
spider-man it seems as though they do
not encounter each other in endgame and
is this figure next to fury Maria Hill
also brought back from the dead or
someone else entirely a character
obviously missing from the trailer is
none other than Tony Stark who is
heavily featured with spider-man in both
his first appearance in Civil War and
homecoming and this line from Hogan all
alone sounds quite ominous but this be
hinting at the death of Tony Stark and
Avengers and game or maybe it's just
Marvel trying to throw us off the plot
whatever happens the future doesn't look
so promising for Iron Man also featured
in the trailer are the many suits Peter
wears during his trip in Europe in the
beginning Peter where's the classic red
and blue suit that we saw in homecoming
of course things don't go according to
plan as Nick Fury makes an appearance to
set Peter on a mission we see two main
suits featured in the trailer one suit
that closely resembles the classic suit
but with a darker palette and wings the
same wings we only briefly saw in
homecoming are now featured more
prominently seemingly allowing Peter to
effortlessly glide through the sky we
also get a better look at the noir suit
from the spider-man noir series set in
1933 also featured recently in
spider-man into the spider-verse
voiced by Nicolas Cage judging by the
nighttime setting maybe this is the suit
of choice when the job requires stealth
over well aesthetics it was long rumored
that a group of villains known as the
elementals were going to make an
appearance in the film the elementals
first made an appearance in the series
supernatural thrillers and are composed
of four extra dimensional villains who
each control different elements Hellfire
who controls fire hi John who can
water and Magnum who manipulates earthen
Rock the only one missing is Zephyr who
has the power to control air but Zephyr
his presence is possibly hinted at by
this lightning when they attacked the
London Bridge these villains however
could also be Sandman molten man and
hydro man other super villains who also
control different elements to fight
against spider-man this is hinted at by
these numbers on the boat behind med hey
SM - 1 - alluding to the amazing
spider-man issued to one - where hydro
man makes his first appearance whether
the villains are really the elementals
or someone else we'll have to wait and
see last but most importantly we finally
get our first look at Mysterio one of
spider-man's main villains played by
Jake Gyllenhaal fans of the original
comic will be happy to see him in the
fishbowl helmet featured in the comics
the only difference is that it seems as
though Mysterio is on spider-man side
fighting against the bad guys there have
been numerous rumors about Nick Fury
teaming spider-man out with Mysterio to
fight the elementals and Mysterio being
a complex morally ambiguous villain so
how does a Mysterio go from fighting
alongside spider-man to fighting against
him or to speculate a bit is it possible
that the elementals are actually just an
illusion created by Mysterio whose main
power in the comics is creating
illusions to deceive his enemies a
similar storyline was featured in the
animated series of spider-man where
Mysterio used illusions to manipulate
the city painting spider-man as the
villain and himself as the hero could
this possibly be what we're seeing in
the trailer it seems like Peters friends
are convinced that he's a hero
he's like Iron Man Thor rolled into one
are you convinced so what did you think
about this trailer what are your
theories and speculations leave it in
the comments and see you at the theaters
in July
you